alright check this out New York City's
morgues are expected to hit their 900
body capacity in 7 days as it asks FEMA
for emergency assistance in the military
set up refrigerated trucks outside
Manhattan's Bellevue Hospital as the
city's death toll nears 200 the first
thing I'm going to say take a look at
these photos so this is I guess these
are FEMA emergency tents or something
they're trying to expand the capacity of
these hospitals and I don't get it man
people are saying it's not real like on
Twitter they're like I don't know
anybody who's got it just because you
can't see it doesn't mean it's not real
people yeah yeah what was what's the
famous pose from Kurt Cobain
no no just because you're paranoid
doesn't mean they're not after you yeah
but it's what's interesting too is over
on the the Donald Trump website they're
like big forum someone posted like
serious question do you know anybody who
has this and all the comments like yes
yes I do they're like my you know
housekeeper like my wife sister or
something things like that so yeah
what's crazy is how quickly these
hospitals are filling up yeah and we
have a couple viral videos interestingly
after this is not calling it this is not
the the video like from the New York
Times but this is showing clips in the
New York Times so the reason why you
don't see any photos or videos from
inside hospitals the first big reason no
nobody's thinking about filming anything
like people are dying not only that but
the average person isn't going back into
the ER like I don't know every how maybe
I'm wrong but every house but I've been
to like there's a lobby and you can't go
anywhere unless they call you in in the
doors are sealed right yeah exactly
there you go so maybe we should expect
to see more filming in the lobby but
dude yeah I'll tell you something man
if you're in the lobby of a hospital you
what about your phone start filming
people I look at these people what
you're gonna get hit that's nice
yeah but I mean someone's gonna hit you
they're gonna be like yo what are you
doing we're in a hospital man yeah and
let alone going into it but then there's
also HIPPA you can't like where's that
stand for the health information privacy
portability act or something there you
go yeah the doctors can't do it but we
did get this doctor at what it was is
like Elmhurst Hospital in New York and
she went around filming inside the
hospital showing how bad it is and it's
it's pretty bad
and then she's basically saying we don't
have what we need the governor is wrong
people are wearing trash bags yeah yup
because it's getting bad yeah we have
this viral video so this is a iain miles
chong tweeted this out he said this is
really hard to watch please keep telling
me to stop please keep telling me to
stop overreacting whenever I post about
the corona virus and it's this video
where I guess it's not gonna play
whatever but this this like she's an
he's an RN I think yeah what does that
mean register registered nurse yeah
she's driving and she's saying that she
just had her first shift and she's like
what what is this she's like to people
like everyone's freaking out they're
rushing around there to I'm left with
these two people who are like on
ventilators dying so she she wasn't able
to like be in touch with doctors cuz
they're freaking slammed and he was
literally providing all of the cares for
two people who are yep basically dying
both of them on ventilators I think yeah
that's a lot of people yeah
critical mass yeah yup or reaching it
soon I kind of feel like what what more
can like what do we do you know cuz like
here's the thing man what do we even
talk about what do we even say about
this it's just getting worse and worse
every day
do we say the same thing every day do we
come on hey guys thanks for tuning in
the the robe signing again and it's
worse than yesterday yes you know that's
show for tonight it was worse than it
was
well we were talking about it we're
gonna watch the hunt yes we're gonna do
something yes and we're gonna talk about
tomorrow yeah we're gonna review a movie
tomorrow switch things up a little bit
you know for me especially it's like I
wake up every day and I read all of this
news yeah and then you know I was like
man we should do a new show we could
talk about other things and the weapons
yeah and I'm like oh man and everything
stops working but I wonder you know I'm
not gonna be afraid to talk about what
I'm about to talk about cuz I know a lot
of people would refuse to do it but is
there a positive that comes out of all
of this there are many positives like
what feels like we're gonna bring our
manufacturing back to America that's
good that's a good that is a good thing
yeah let's let's do it let's start let's
let's make this a positive segment I
said I was talking about hospitals being
overrun with corpses I started a list on
Twitter of positives of this
I came up with a really long list did I
need to go back and find it did anybody
get offended no everybody was like oh
yeah I thought of some yeah
manufacturing coming back is a good
thing
yes spending time with your family is a
good thing you know what I'm reminded of
that meme of the political compass where
every quadrant gets what they want
yeah what was it the authoritarian left
is happy that the corporation's are
collapsing the libertarian left is happy
that the environment is healing the
libertarian right is happy that the
governments are collapsing and the
authoritarian right is happy that
borders are being closed hmm everybody
gets a little bit right I think a lot of
people are gonna start growing their own
food also yeah hope they do I think
that's pretty huge
I mean it's I've been saying it for
years why do we have grass right what is
seriously good for rolling around in you
know what nobody that's default yes it's
like it was a like a standard like
what's there was um who's who in the
neighborhood has the nicest green grass
no no but where did that come from
before that like what's the root of this
yeah I don't know
no it's cuz grass is just there yeah
okay so like you're I'm gonna build a
house and you build a house and you're
surrounded by grass and then you're like
the grass is too tall so you cut a path
and then someone's you know the grass is
just is grass and invasive species is
that fair to say I don't know probably
the grass we grow now Kentucky bluegrass
or what I'm having more fun talking
about grass that I am talking about
crime virus Burma permaculture we got
what is that it's growing your own stuff
yeah yeah started recycling everything
learning how to live off the land again
yeah yeah it's like we've lost that as
humans like yeah if everything just
stopped working as it kind of looks like
it's gonna stop working everyone needs
to learn how to handle their own stuff
and say their own stuff I had a really
important at an interesting idea for
like a fantasy themed for like a game or
something okay where I was imagining how
we're centralizing all of these
different industries okay
we've got major fracking hubs in like
North Dakota area oil at pipelines and
stuff like that then you've got you know
China producing all the rare earths and
I'm thinking like if if it's cheaper to
have a shipping like vessel with all
these cargo containers like let me stop
something I'll explain
skateboards right how are they made they
chop a treat under Canada send the wood
to China the Chinese laborers turned it
into a skateboard and send it back to
California and then it's sent over the
US that's insane I know it's we we have
we have rocked maples in America we can
cut down run and sustainably harvest and
then make skateboards out of or or make
bamboo boards or yeah or even bamboo
boards which which which they do a nice
pop they do but they flop out real quick
like they don't don't last as long
that's true they're don't but you know
hey hey I'll take me I'll take a
sustainable board of its bamboo right
exactly yes anyway my heads up I started
thinking about this like if we're
seriously gonna take our wood and send
it to China to make a skateboard what
would the future of this reality look
like in a hundred years and so I was
thinking of a world where no one in the
United States has any idea how to make
anything electronic at all like if we
went down this path so you have regions
that specialize specifically in one
thing is cheaper true so it's like you
know you have look you have a company
that says we need electronic you know
component manufactured goes to China and
then China has these weird like states
that are just like the entire culture is
making phone the entire culture is
mining rare earths the entire culture is
making skateboards making skateboards
yeah so that's like a future that
doesn't make sense and so now we're
seeing everything kind of flip back like
the pendulum just crashed in the wall
and it's swinging back the other way
or got stuck there yeah after just put
in the wall like it just was like and
we're like waiting for it to continue
back or something but nope nope we're
just stuck here just chillin I think
we're gonna have to start recognizing
the there's there's there's two ways out
of this we destroy the economy which
results in lots of people dying yeah or
we slowly go back to work which results
in lots of people dying yeah great
options is there a third I got I'm not
yeah which is which do we have less
deaths with you know what's gonna be the
better option I feel like that would be
the one who wherever less people die
there's nothing you can say because
you'll get attacked no matter what from
both sides I can say very easily I don't
want people to die yeah you can say that
right and go ahead and try to attack
yeah so prevent that are you gonna
prevent people committing suicide when
they lose their job or you know prevent
them know it's 6 million new
unemployment three point three three
point three let's not even talk about
suicides I'm talking about people who
lose their
lose their food right you have research
cameras released our catch coronavirus
and they're not getting the nutrients
and then it's like even if they were
healthy they don't even have the
nutrients for their body to like create
anything to fight it it's like this it's
a delicate situation we're in right now
yep so Trump says the economy's got to
get started and here's what I've been
thinking
he's a trade guy right he's not he's not
he's not a PhD economist turning like
that right but he knows trade so he's
looking at this from a trade perspective
the doctors are looking from a health
perspective but neither understands each
other it is a fact if the economy tanks
we don't get it back and it will be
worse because then without a working
economy there are no supplies there is
no technology there is no cure and then
the coronavirus comes in right
afterwards yeah so what do we do do we
open it back up and then just be like
well then people are gonna die well I
mean Falchi said it's cyclical it's
coming around it's gonna be it's not
going away yeah the people that yeah I
mean it's it's you know man it's
spreading in the in the warm places of
earth where it's supposed to be summer
and there's they were like you know
trying to see if it was like well maybe
you know the heat would kill it off but
it's spreading I think we're going to
have to realize that the you know we've
we've grown our generation of
degeneration into this position where we
think death isn't a thing that happens
right there was a period like we talked
about the other day like I was talking
about how I went to Glenn Beck studio
and he had this newspaper on the wall
all these old papers and I was reading
one where it was like a dude was outside
of a bar smoking and then some guy
walked up and just blasted him in the
chest you know that was pistol no but
know these things happen today go to
Chicago man that people pull out guns
and they shoot it yeah so I think you
know maybe we've come to a point where
we've put ourselves in this bubble
that's so secure we're now Slyke
we'vewe've we're gonna burn ourselves
down because we refuse to accept that
hey man look pandemics and viruses
happen and they hurt people you know we
want to mitigate that for sure save as
many lives as possible but shutting down
the entire economy because now the u.s.
is the has the most infected people on
the planet yeah it's like what 83,000
and if we if we kick-start the economy
back up
that's gonna jump gonna go nuts and
we're and and what are they estimating
like on the high end six or seven
million dead yeah out of three hundred
twenty seven million yeah
the low end it's like one point two
that's insane like you got to realize
man 9/11 was you know around three
thousand people and that was a
horrifying shock to this nation yeah and
now we're already at a thousand which
means in another week this could be more
deaths than 9/11 it's not the same I
understand but in many ways it's in many
ways not every way but it could be worse
we don't really have a comparison
anymore
the last thing like this that happened
was a hundred years ago yeah and we've
just there's no frame of reference
life's never been that hard for us are
we gonna return to a pragmatic stoic
world probably people are gonna just be
alike sometimes people die yeah back to
work I mean that's it's yeah people are
in their comfortable bubble and
everybody's bubbles popping I know we're
realizing we're we're all humans that
are susceptible no matter who you are
doesn't matter who you are you can be
rich rich people are getting it but
they're mostly getting it yeah because
they fly around all the time and they're
more likely to eat infected that's true
yeah you're right yeah but there are
almost people get in there young people
getting it
we're hearing more and more stories
about young people getting it that's the
point everyone is susceptible everybody
we're all humans were all whoever you
are your bubble if you're comfortable
and you think death can't catch you you
are in let me tell you something New
York New York City had or I think New
York State I'm sorry 100 deaths in the
past 24 hours so everybody's been saying
the flu is worse the flu is worse all
right according to the CDC from October
to February we had 12,000 deaths that
comes out to just about four deaths per
hour in the US New York alone in one day
had four deaths per hour that's just one
state so there we go
New York has just surpassed the national
numbers for the for the low-end estimate
for the CDC on flu deaths so it is gonna
get worse and if we do open up the
economy then well what do you think's
gonna happen it's gonna shoot up more
it's gonna be a wave I mean they pose a
cladding that well we're testing more
now so you're gonna see a spike don't
don't fear this bike we're testing more
yeah but our number of deaths are going
up as well yeah right so is this just
the end no there's any way out of this
I mean what's what's the percentage of
people it's killing you know in the u.s.
actually lower out of the rest of the
world okay we got good hospitals man as
much people out a lot of activists would
argue we don't I think it's around like
between like 0.8 and like 1.5 so the
well I mean you can look at the number
right there like the best percentage is
low you know so you know it's it's when
you don't see it you know when it when
it's not in your face you know it's you
see all these numbers you know and it's
like we can talk about these numbers but
you know it's not tangible because I
don't see it you know and I'm not I
don't know anybody who has it so I'm not
it's it's hard to like even talk about
it you know with this such salt you know
a solid statement on it because I don't
know I don't know yeah it's the world's
definitely scary and I I know I'm scared
and I think that that is kind of where
everyone's at everyone's everyone's
afraid doesn't matter who you are you
know it's like a certain degree well
yeah exactly
some people want to watch the world burn
yeah sure there are a lot of jokers out
there men yeah that's true laughing
about it encouraging the worst they're
gonna they're gonna laugh about it until
the person they love catches it there
was a lady who went into a store and
heard cotton and this is not too far for
me I started coughing on all the produce
and they'd just dump it all and she was
like laughing so I was funny there are
people looking toilets to think it's
funny there are people who are licking
you don't think it's funny
people are spitting on nurses and
doctors when they go out and they're
scrubs people are awful whoa yeah
where's that story at it's all over the
place that's happening in India it's
happening here in the US oh that's right
yeah like doctors are getting kicked out
of their houses because they're being
evicted yeah and there was that
paramedic was evicted in the UK by a
lady who by his landlady who texted him
because she didn't want coronavirus
I'll tell you what man this morning when
I was looking at the news when I was
listening to the bickering between the
political parties I have never been more
pessimistic about our chances here never
do you know what happened in Venezuela
and when would you just like over the
past several years no I don't know we
got a print more money and you and give
that so they have a bunch of
unemployment right and they think they
can just print money to buy their way
out of their problems in Venezuela yeah
okay and and this happens in socialist
countries because it doesn't work they
start dumping money and then all of a
sudden I went to Venezuela man I had
stacks of cash and it was like this big
we had a garbage bag full of full of
Venezuelan bills it was uh it was the
it's called the bowl of our I think it
was and you couldn't do anything with it
like this big bag of like I think I had
a hundred at the time this is crazy too
at the time when I went a stack like
this big was a hundred bucks the
equivalent okay and so I brought it back
and I'm like boom on a table I'm like
bling-bling and we all started laughing
cuz it's like it's worthless yeah well
no I was like Worth's Drive a hundred
bucks okay it's got value but like this
massive stack of cash and so they were
like what are we gonna do with this
nobody wants anything from Venezuela and
it's because they just started printing
money yeah that's what that's what we're
doing right now that's what the stimulus
package is right print money what do we
have like six trillion dollars now the
debt was already really high and now
they're printing all this money it's
like it's we're gonna see I'm worried
we're gonna see runaway inflation yep so
let's let's do this let's uh let's take
a look at let's see if we got this
alright check this out the cost of
household staples milk eggs and bread
skyrocket by up to thirty percent as
panic buying leaves retailers grappling
with supply shortages I'm gonna come
back to this but we have this story for
the New York Times frequently asked
questions on stimulus checks
unemployment and the coronavirus bill in
the short term I have good news
apparently according to New York Times
you don't got to do anything you're just
gonna get a check it's gonna show up oh
they're not making us pay it back no no
as a stimulus meaning they just give you
the money okay so when it comes to the
stimulus
what they basically say is that you
don't even have to let me see if I can
pull this up would I have to apply to
receive payment no if the Internal
Revenue Service already has your bank
account information it would transfer
the money to you via direct deposit
based on the recent income tax figures
it already has so if you already filed
your taxes for this year it'll use 2019
if you haven't it'll use 2018 you're
just gonna wake up one day with money in
the bank that's good in the short term
right you can go to the store you can
order on Amazon and get what you need to
get there's a problem in this solves
nothing
agreed and I got I got no beef with the
people trying to do the stimulus but all
the restaurants and all the retail shops
that are out of business right now that
are should that are shut down or
furloughed or whatever yeah yeah a
stimulus isn't gonna put anything into
that and what about rent my rent was
twelve hundred bucks a month yeah dude
okay so no it's not a rental listen to
nothing else it's barely a band-aid it's
not it's not even a band-aid
this will furnish short it's a kiss on
the boo-boo there's nothing there's
nothing they can do like I'm not saying
this as beef to the Republicans and the
Democrats you know because I've been
critical of the Democrats holding it up
for a bit the Republicans then held it
up for certain provisions so we'll see a
little back-and-forth but the reality is
if the business is shut down where you
spend the money anyway yeah there was
there was this really sad post I saw a
family pizza shop they said I'm sorry
you know after 40 years we are
officially out of business because these
these businesses are operating on very
slim margins yeah I think they're like a
only a few percentage points they were
it was a small pizza that was not you
know super wealthy they closed those
jobs are gone this is why it bothers me
to see people say oh it's just big
corporations right help the little lude
I mean but even the big corporations I
get it man Boeing has a lot of employees
of every 70,000 or whatever have
thousands of employees it's not even
that the airlines are basically
operating it like no capacity they're
essentially shutting down owns traveling
anyway congratulations you're gonna
twelve under bucks we can do with it
we're gonna buy those rednecks like I'm
sure online shops of
shot through the roof though online
shops yeah everyone has internets
there's there's stuff to buy and they're
FedEx and UPS are essential so they're
they're still running they're still you
know people are doing their shopping
online but what portion they've done
anyway but what portion of the economy
is like local bars and restaurants and
retail shops a lot massive portion
that's true Walgreens CVS Rite Aid Duane
Reade nothing no more cash flow well I
mean if this is seriously the way it's
gonna be like humanity will look a lot
different in about a year we will adjust
but it's gonna be weird I think no
matter what anyone tries to do we are
going like you're right it's going to be
a dramatic transformation mm-hmm we're
gonna be fine and you know what you said
yesterday I think it's we're gonna see
technological advances like we've never
seen well uh methodological advances
this still it's gonna happen so the way
I'd explain it is we're gonna see an
application of technology not seen
before yeah so one of the things that
that's that's you know that we see a lot
more of is the application of drive
throughs for even medical testing right
so now there's not reporting that
Walgreens for instance you can pull up
to Walgreens at the pharmacy drive-thru
and say milk bread next please and
they'll be like here you are sir why
can't we do that now that's a good
question
and that's a methodology not a
technology but using a mobile app yeah
you can go on your phone and do milk
bread eggs Boop and then they can see on
the app where you are and then they see
you pulling up and they grab the stuff
and they go to the window and you pull
up and they say yeah that's true and one
of your videos earlier you said like you
were talking about shops are still
staying open because you can actually
call them
yep and be like I would like to purchase
this please and they walk out and give
it to you right that's pretty cool but
think about how like uber works okay you
press the app and then you're looking
and you're watching the little car come
to you and you're like and they're
outside and then you know to go outside
because you see them pulling up the
inverse is true for curbside delivery
you go in the Best Buy app and you're
gonna be like I need to buy this here
laptop for work and then you pull up and
right before you get there they see you
pulling up on the street just like you
would see the driver and they say oh
he's pulling up okay great and then they
grant
outside and right when you walk right
when you pull up they walk outside here
you are mr. Kriegler you wave and you
turn around you're gone the future is
here so it but but these are these are
interesting changes I'm talking about
like what we're just watching that Rick
and Morty episode where then let the Mad
Max world yeah I'm talking about like
Mad Max changes well I mean didn't you
say something I think yesterday UPS is
designing drones at that 560 miles an
hour our wind resistant yep and
obviously to deliver packages imma shoot
alright Manning we need two things right
now we need Boston Dynamics right these
are the guys who make those robots
they're like a evil crazy waves
I didn't man and I demand massive
government funding all right full-on
communists no I'm kidding
well III want them to develop that to
the point where they can be fully
autonomous they can operate for 16 hours
and then we need neroli and then we
create the world of surrogates where we
have like an avatar version of ourselves
I almost watched that movie the other
day yeah I gotta watch it III thought I
was a fun movie I like sir it's
interesting um how cool it'd be like a
ghost in the shell' kind of world where
you have like this crazy robot body
you could go skating and you wouldn't
care because you're damaging your you
know avatar instead of wouldn't be the
same I want to feel the pain right you
want to feel but you'd feel the rush
you'd be in you know I slammed my my my
arm today like I got a huge knot right
here and it feels so good right because
afterwards I landed the trick that I was
trying to land and I was like yes oh
this is the pain that I'll throw in this
pan but I'll throw this out there like
slamming feels good it does it like I
know that's what I'm talking about it
hurts
and you're like oh it hurts me that's so
good
I think that's a high tea thing as
opposed to the low tea guys oh yeah okay
it hurts
I hate sinners I hate whacking my ankles
I do too but like it feels so it
converts into I don't want to call it
anger fuel but it is kind of anger but
it is sort of like motivational fuel
like there's no one to be angry at right
but are you gonna be mad at the board
people do that I know they throw the
board and like he didn't do anything
well let's say they
Yeah right words of heat so will there
be skateboards in the new world to love
no it's a luxury item absolutely
luxury item an I mean people the
skateboards were made on you know like
in the backyards of people who couldn't
surf and they they scrambled them all
together to surf on the roads so it's
like sure it's not necessity but it'll
be a thing thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you